this is a security engineer they need to
understand the newest vulnerabilities
and find out if they have any
mitigations to do based on their Cloud
infrastructure and logging they need to
know what their exposure is and are
hoping to use duet Ai and Google Cloud
to help them take corrective action if
needed let's observe the security
engineer in their natural habitat as
they use duet AI to simpli ify the task
at hand first our security engineer
wonders what are the latest threats they
should be aware of let's start with a
view of the latest threat intelligence
for mandiant helpfully gathered Allin
one place for consumption wo thousands
and thousands of results just for one
threat actor our engineer doesn't have
time to read all that luckily they can
get a quick summary thanks to the AI
helper picking one prominent threat the
engineer wants to dig deeper but this is
just showing a big massive metadata
confusing and
overwhelming they start with the duet AI
generated summary on the sidebar to give
them a faster way to understand what
this threat actor is trying to do and
where the security engineer needs to
know if they're vulnerable to any of
these attack patterns luckily they can
do a plain language search in chronicle
to find out if any of these attacks are
hitting their
infrastructure well this is both good
and bad the good part they've got some
results without having to navigate the
Arcane udm syntax the bad part looks
like they had some hits so some crypto
mining attacks are going on let's find
out more once again we see our security
engineer swamped with information lots
of cases lots of Windows lots of
statistics help us do at AI summary
you're our only
hope hooray it's right here and shows
them exactly what they needed now time
to spring into action they go directly
to security Command Center for actions
to respond to the detected
threats no more Mountains of metadata
luckily they've got duet here to
summarize and give them a quick guide
towards mitigation actions summary red
and digested it's time for the engineer
to unwind with watering their
plants what will you
[Music]
build